[Music]
[Music]
Super Smash Brothers ultimate willpotter
we've been playing a bunch of it in the
office it's become our lunchtime game of
choice hasn't it
you've been playing lots and lots of it
in fact I don't think you've done any
work for about a week so what I'm
interested in
slash has always been a hugely
impressive multiplayer experience and
for me the best multiplayer experience
so far on switch is Mario Kart 8 so I
want to know whether you think now that
Smash Brothers ultimate is a on switch
do you think as a multiplayer experience
that has overtaken America I think so
and and the reason for me is that I
don't get on with fighting games but
I've been playing smash ever since the
n64 version because it's so accessible
and I think you can hand a pad to anyone
and they can pretty much pick up the
gist of Smash Brothers and then apply
that to what 70ish characters that there
are on that roster which is mad and that
just makes it like an infinite amount of
fun but with what you can have out that
game
[Applause]
in Smash it's like you can tailor make
an experience for a multiplayer game
that you want with your friends you can
have up to 8 people and it's madness of
course you could have a 1v1 very serious
fighting game no items final destination
no mace no weapons no mates you can have
that if you want but I think it's far
more fun if you have 4 or 5 6 7 8 people
just going absolutely bonkers on a map
tracking items and if even if someone's
never played it before they're gonna
have a lot of fun even if they don't win
it's just fun to watch yeah yeah I mean
I definitely agree that there's some
merit in that and it is funny when you
know there is a bunch of you on screen
at once and you smash your mate
off-screen and they lose a life and and
you can shove it in their face but I
think what I would say is that it
especially when you have the more people
you add the worse this becomes it
becomes so chaotic that all strategy
just goes out of the window and and I'm
someone who's played a bit of smash over
the years but probably not as much as
you I don't really know what I'm doing
so I'm just there like mashing buttons
essentially and I feel like and I feel
like I'm mashing buttons it's not like
in America I feel like you can I feel
like you can hand the controller to
someone who's never played America
before but it's so easy to understand
when you've got a deep work go faster
than everyone else right and so even and
if you do drop behind then you get a
great weapon you get a bullet bill or
you get a blue shell or whatever and
that makes you feel like you're doing
really well even if you're not
[Music]
whereas with smash I think I don't think
it has that same amount of balance to it
if you're struggling in smash you really
feel like you're struggling like we were
playing yesterday although I was having
fun playing with you guys I was by far
the worst out of the four of us and and
and I felt like the worst I mean I felt
like I wasn't able to bridge that that
skill gap so I don't know do you feel
like smash has that that ability to make
it satisfying even if you're not very
good at the game I agree there's there's
definitely like an initial learning
curve whereas Mario Kart is obviously
just drive around the track which is
yeah you know people get that it's easy
whereas smash there's a bit more to
learn there are rules there is like
smashing people off the stage and you
can like I said you can tailor make it
you can give people handicaps you can
customize items if it is just eight
people going at it
you can pick characters who are sort of
like on the sidelines sort of sniping
chucking things in you could be Kirby
and just float up above everyone it has
dropped down but I think in the in the
fact that you know every every character
plays differently but they also plays
play the same you know after you've got
that initial knowledge of smash you can
apply that to pretty much any character
it's not like you're learning a brand
new combo and Street Fighter where this
is a fighting game that is accessible
just from learning the first character
I suppose with like Mario Kart yes you
have like assists and things don't you
so you can make it easier and I get that
like a blue shell like it's a way that
merica equalizes that game and balances
it for people however that is also very
frustrating for someone who's very good
and then is about to cross the finish
line and just get blue shells red shells
banana skins that's everything at once
I see incredibly frustrating but I think
that's where the comedy of Mario Kart
Castle and that's where like this kid's
game turns into a mature or a is like
this where fast
[Music]
so we talked about the accessibility and
what these two games are like for
newcomers but looking at the other end
of the spectrum do you think I mean
we're still playing America 8 america 8
deluxe to be precise years after the
game first came out on Wii U do you
think we're still going to be playing
Smash Brothers ultimate in four years
time five years time do you think it's
got that same depth that Mario Kart
clearly for us does have it's a good is
a good question and a smash is a funny
one because like I don't think people
are playing the Wii U version anymore no
the the competitive version is Mellie
from the Gamecube days right I think
smash ultimate though brings so much and
has so much packed into that game that
it's like an infinite number of
combinations of fun that you can have so
the number of maps which all have a
couple of forms each as well number of
items the different modes and you can
set up your own sort of these are my
favorite game modes so like stock
stamina timed you can add different
things settings in there like the smash
meter you can have different items and
you can really customize that experience
and keep changing it and there's just
fund are things you could give any
everyone bunny ears or make everyone
made out of metal it's that fun
combinations that you can apply to the
multiplayer experience that constantly
keep it fresh
[Music]
we're just like only scratching the
surface at the moment of yeah this game
has and there's so much in there that I
just can't see us getting tired of it
anytime see yeah there's definitely a
lot of content isn't there and I think
in fairness I think the same is true of
America I think that's probably a large
reason why we're still playing it you
know four and a half years after it
first came out but I think merica has
has a lot of what you just spoke about
there it's got lots of characters it's
got lots of Trax's they've added more in
DLC as well and I think a lot of the DLC
tracks obviously they weren't DLC for
deluxe they were DLC for the original
America on Wii U but I think some of the
DLC tracks were absolutely amazing
[Music]
I think that's a large part of why we're
still playing America and it also has a
lot of those options you were talking
about as well probably not to the same
extent as smash and I think smash you
probably can tailor a little bit more
you know you can clearly change whether
you want it to be all against all or a
team race or there's a proper battle
mode now in deluxe baby now I will still
if they don't release America at 9:00
anytime soon I'll still be playing that
game in ten years time yeah Mary carts
be fair is a very good game like you
can't really floor that game in any way
for me though I just think eventually I
get tired of the tracks eventually I get
tired of you know those races and it's
nice to pick up every now and again and
have it as the Mario Kart game whereas
in Smash there's you know you could play
the same map over and over and every
time it's gonna be different and
arguably yes it's the same Ameri Kart
but just the number of variables going
on in Smash just mean that it's wildly
different like the number of characters
and items and moments in that game that
happen you know they're one in a million
I think the moments in Smash where is
Mario Kart yes it's it's great and it's
fun to keep replaying those tracks but
eventually it's it's not going to feel
as fresh or as interesting as Super
Smash Bros
[Music]
so bill the holiday season is I mean
it's already upon us isn't it which is
it seems to get an early revelation by
your jumpers I mean I wear this year
right the holiday season's coming you've
got enough money in your pocket to buy
one switch game to play with your family
this Christmas which one of you buy a
new buy America eight or you buying
Super Smash Brothers ultimate the family
I think Mario Kart is just a bit more
accessible okay but for friends and for
people who are into games
I think Smash just has way more going on
and for me that's more fun and
interesting to play at this point
especially now that while Mario Kart 8
deluxe is like a great great game really
solid game it is getting on now it does
feel like we're do a numeric art in the
next year or two whereas smash is brand
new there's new things to come new
characters there's events happening it
feels like a dynamic game that is
there's you know it's alive now whereas
Marriott deluxe is old and I think flat
reason I'd probably choose smash how
about you I mean I would go with Mario
Cart still yeah I would yeah I've just
purely because I think I think it is
more accessible and even as someone
who's played I would have probably put
in 300 hours or more of America probably
more than that to be honest and I still
feel like I enjoy it as much now as I
did when I first got it so I still have
that depth having said that if if you
around my house at Christmas bill and
you'd bought Smash strange I'd be
perfectly happy to sit there and have a
game with you take a beating as well I
don't know what kind of Christmas you
have in your house all right guys those
were our thoughts on Super Smash
Brothers ultimate and Mario Kart 8
deluxe the Nintendo switch and which of
those is the best multiplayer game let's
move your thoughts on which game you're
gonna be playing with your friends and
family this Christmas in the comments
section below or you can come yell at us
on Twitter I'm at their said I'm at of
the quiff is dead as always thanks for
watching and we'll catch you next time
slash
[Music]